did you warn your parents that you were
doing this yeah
yeah mm-hmm they must have been excited
based off your reaction
my dad was more excited is your dad
aware of my existence
on this planet um i
i think they've seen conan without
borders but i did have to remind my mum
who you are yeah is your is your mom she
sounds like she's a rabid fan
of mine uh is she is she the kind of
person that if she was exposed to my
comedy would she
would she like it or is that not her cup
of tea
no um be honest it's fine this is a safe
space
we're in we're in your attic right now
that actually comes into my question for
you
um and it's that why doesn't my mum like
american humor
oh so that first question is answered
then i think okay
i show her a lot i think you could just
play her this
and that would answer all the questions
you need she doesn't like
uh american television she doesn't like
american comedy
i i it's yes the comedy i've been trying
we've been going through parks and
recreation at the moment
that's an excellent show if she
sometimes likes it
but some episodes it just ends with her
saying
it's okay but that's like a direct
descendant of the british office
so what does she say to that i i i don't
think she liked that either to be fair
oh oh so it's not that she disapproves
of america very critical
she's just very critical yeah is she
critical of mr robot as well
you're watching miss you you're you are
watching mr robot with her
with my mum and my dad and my dad loves
it
my mom doesn't and she
she really should leave the room she
sits there with like a newspaper
and just kind of looks up with
disapproval every now and then
wow i know that's cool what does she
like
like what is she into like eastenders
that's the only
british show i can think of what is
there chutney brothers in the bubble
touch
gang or whatever it is um does she learn
deficiency does she like
the great british baking show nope never
got into that
oh my god what did she like does she
like here's my question
and you can help us cut to the chase
loose what does she like
is there anything that she gets excited
about and she puts the newspaper down
and watches it with glee
would i lie to you it's a panel show and
you have to find out whether people are
lying or not sounds rubbish when i say
is it good do you like it yeah it's a
great show
oh i actually agree with her on that
okay so her
um she loves watching a pathological
liar
and trying to catch them uh in a slip up
that's
she should love this show
[Laughter]
i've said so far today lewis is true
well i think
um it sounds like your mother if i had
to guess your mother
i think is trying to protect herself
it sounds to me like she's building a
bit of a defensive wall
if you're going to jump into a world of
watching different shows and exposing
yourself to
the arts you need to let go a little bit
your father's up for it but your mother
is not and it's safe for her what's the
paper that you guys like to read is it
the guardian
is it the it's the sun this isn't yeah
is that the one that has all the naked
women in it
it used to i'm always shocked that would
be on an international flight and they
would say would you like the british
newspaper and i'd say well yes please
thinking that
it would be this very stuffy affair and
uh i'd open it up and
it'd be nineteen three page three just
and wow you're just the page oh my god
trust me and i was
i started getting on i started flying
airlines just to get that paper
um and i would steal all the page threes
but these
incredibly uh sexy ladies uh right there
sometimes uh quite exposed in the
newspaper we don't have that in this
country usa today wouldn't stand for it
um yeah we have high standards yes they
insist a pie chart is about as
successful as
sexy as it got at usa today but my guess
is that your mother feels
safe holding that paper up and kind of
hiding behind it
and choosing this defensive posture what
do you think louis
yeah i think so i think it's a shield
and i think
i will break it one day i will break it
but it sounds like it
sounded violent i meant more yeah
it sounds like it's mainly you said for
american shows so
no she has an issue with america she's
critical of all
shows but i think american humor
especially ah
well i have to agree with her that i
think there's a lot out there
uh in america that's that's not good
i you know i'm not allowed to toot my
own horn but i see myself as a
lonely bastion a lighthouse in the fog
if you will
trying to set the standard trying to
raise the standard but
uh you know it's a lonely uh profession
that i've chosen to be
uh so good and what i do for so but your
mom doesn't know who conan is right
is that what you said earlier okay i
just wanted to remind you that his mom
didn't know who you were
just in case you forgot no i remember
now